je ne suis pas une affectation au
service de protection des hautes
personnalités
si vous êtes venus pour rencontrer des
gens du showbiz allez vous vous êtes
trompés d'endroit
il ya des caméras dans toutes les
chambres voulait dire qu'on a accès aux
jardins secrets des stars
ok j'adore ce job la seule chose que
j'ai proposé une chanteuse est devenue
trop violent non mais c'est de
travailler dans la finesse quand il pose
comme un crs déjà acheté réintégrer été
compilées à partir d'un service bien
mieux formés possible
moi je vous mettrais direct on va très
bien s'entendre
c'est moi général on s'est mis lui
tourne je sais qu'ils se débrouillent
moi je conçois les charges et de
protection
non non non non mon malheur vous
attendez le prochain merci c'est moi
c'est sécurisant je vous en prie je lui
tends à compans danseurs 38 détachement
à toi qui fout
j'te dis
voiture c'est bon j'ai tout filmé ça sur
youtube ses amis d'en but direct si tu
mens pas dans la voiture on va faire
deux millions de vues d'accord
c'est un [ __ ] de comics ou bien des le
mec de revenge avec un tapin l'a bien
choisir vient salopards contre une par
une à fond le bourinos que de hausser
conan le barbare
vous n'arrêtez jamais oui
mais ce type j'ai toujours l'impression
qu'il ya des bombes dans les poches
[ __ ] [ __ ] monica économique et sapho
combat pour une pharmacie compte dans la
bétadine je vois un mélange de gros
nounours
slash bourrin ça je suis malheureux
bougie peut le faire